Two followups on yesterday's lack,
I'm sorry,
on,
um,
Monday's lecture.
One is that,
uh,
that somebody came up after class and asked when the preference for your own
language emerges in development.
And fortunately,
uh,
Colleen McCrank,
studies pretty much exactly this sort of infant understanding.
She knew the answer.
There has been studies looking at newborn babies finding that pretty much the
moment they pop out,
they favor their own language over other language,
over other languages.
And this suggests that they are listening while in utero while in the womb to
the rhythms of their language and developing a preference for it.
A second issue is I talked very briefly about a court case in which,
um,
the person was said at a moment where someone else was pointing a gun at a
police officer,
let him have it and a police officer was killed and that person was charged with
murder.
But I admitted I didn't actually know how things turned out and Greg Lawan was
kind enough to do extensive research or he went to Wikipedia and,
um,
and,
and find out the answer to answer is he was tried and found guilty for murder.
He was then subsequently it.
In fact,
he was pardoned in 1988,
which is really nice,
except he was executed in 1957.
Um,
but it did make it into a movie
movie.
Okay.
So what I want to do today for the first part of the lectures,
continue the language lecture and then move to perception,
attention and memory.
And what we have spoken about was we first talked about universals of language,
then move to some detail about,
um,
the different aspects of language,
including phonology,
morphology,
and syntax.
We discussed the ways in which language does the amazing things it does,
including the fact that language is used,
arbitrary signs or sounds to convey concepts and at languages exploit a common
editorial system,
including recursion to put together these symbols into a virtually limitless,
a set of meaningful sentences.
Uh,
we then talked about development and made some remarks about the developmental
time course,
talking about the emergence of language from babies to where babies are really
good at learning language to you who are not,
whose brains have atrophied,
whose language capacities are dead.
Um,
final issue is to shift to animals.
Now that we know something about,
about language,
we could then ask do animals,
um,
use,
possess the same sort of language and if not,
can they learn it?
Now there is absolutely no doubt at all that nonhuman animals possess
communication systems.
This has been known forever.
Um,
and it's not a matter of controversy.
And if you want to use the term language to mean communication,
and the answer is obviously yes,
dogs and bees and monkeys have language.
If you want to use language though in the more technical narrow sense as
anything that has the properties that we discussed earlier using English and ASL
and Spanish and so on.
As our background,
the answer's almost certainly no animal communication systems fall into sort of
one of three categories.
Either there's a finite list of calls.
So vervet monkeys for instance,
have a small list of calls to convey different warnings like attack from a snake
or attack from a leopard.
There's a continuous analog signal,
so be dance for instance,
works on this way.
Be Dance,
communicates the location of food sources but doesn't do it in any syntactically
structured way.
Rather the intensity of the dance corresponds to the richness of the food
source.
And then you get things like random variation on a theme such as bird song,
but when you don't find in any real sense is phonology,
morphology,
syntax,
um,
common editorial systems or arbitrary names.
Now this much is not particularly controversial.
There gets to be a lot of controversy though.
This is the summary,
but non human communication systems,
it gets more controversial when we get to famous cases of primates,
um,
trained by humans such as Kanzi,
Nim chimpsky and other famous primates that you may well have seen on the
discovery channel and other venues.
And this is fairly controversial.
If you read the gray textbook.
Well,
nothing in it is particularly inaccurate.
I think gray is actually a little bit too credulous to believing in the claims
that have been made about the abilities of the animals.
So many scientists,
uh,
argue for instance,
that animals like Kanzi,
even if they can be said to be learning words at all,
learn very few of them.
And it takes them extensive years of training to learn.
Unlike a normally developing child who could learn a word in a day or a word and
an hour,
um,
the,
the utterance is often have order,
but this order tends to be very limited and um,
and,
and lacks the recursive properties.
And in fact the lack of recursion is not controversial.
Um,
finally the utterances of chimpanzees trained chimpanzees are extremely,
um,
repetitive.
So what you often see on TV and then documentaries is it sort of a sampling and
the sampling could often be very impressive.
But if you take just what they say at random,
it tends to look like this.
Um,
this is typical chimpanzee I'd Irwin's has just taken at random.
Nim,
eat name,
eat,
drink,
eat mean.
M Meagan,
Meagan,
me mean in play.
Me Eat me,
eat me.
Banana Yuban enemy you give banana,
Mimi eat,
give orange B,
give,
eat orange.
Me,
Um,
glade once commented that if any normally developing child spoke like this as
parents had rush them screaming to a neurologist.
MMM.
There's a broader question here,
which is why would we ever expect a chimpanzee to learn a human language?
We don't normally expect one species to have the capacities associated with
another species.
So I'm bats use echolocation to get around and some birds navigate by the stars,
but there's not an active research program seeing if cats can use echolocation.
Our dogs could navigate by the stars.
And I think one reason why you might be temped to think,
well of course chimps must be able to learn language is because you might be
caught in the grips of some bad ideas about language.
So one idea is you might say,
look,
Cim should use language because chimps are so smart.
But the response to this is they are smart,
but we know that smart isn't enough.
Okay.
We know that the human capacity for language is not totally result of smartness.
There are smart showrun who due to some deficit in their language capacity,
don't speak or understand a language.
So the smartness of chimpanzees does not in itself demonstrate that they should
be able to learn language.
You might also point out correctly that chimps are nearest evolutionary
relatives,
which is right.
So you one would expect on the face of it,
it's not unreasonable to expect.
MMM.
Asked to share a lot of abilities with them.
On the other hand,
we split from them a long time ago and plainly,
humans are different from chimps and there was 5 million years either way.
And that's more than enough time for language capacity to invoke too
evolve.
Um,
now none of this is to say that his study of nonhuman communication systems
isn't interesting.
MMM.
From my own.
This is my personal opinion.
I'll raise here from my own opinion.
The study of the attempts to try to teach chimpanzees or Gibbons or gorillas,
a human language like ASL are misguided.
Um,
it would be as if a team of monkey is kidnapped a human child and tried to train
them how to hoot like a monkey.
It might be enjoyable,
but it does not seem to give us any rich insights.
What I think is a lot more interesting is the study of these animal
communication systems in the wild.
There's a linguistics of human language that has delineated the principles that
underlie all human languages.
It would be,
it's extraordinarily interesting to attempt the same linguistic program to the
other communication systems use in the wild,
such as the cries of vervet monkeys and B dance.
So this brings the section on language to a close,
but I want to tell you a few things we didn't talk about.
One of the problems with an intro psych courses,
we have to whip through a lot of topics very fast.
So if you were to take a course that focused directly on language,
you might learn,
for instance,
more about language and the brain.
Something touched about very briefly in a textbook,
but something that has a large literature associated with it.
Similarly and related to this,
there's language disorders,
disorders like Aphasia as and disorders like specific language impairment and
dyslexia.
There's a study of language perception and production.
How is it that we do this amazing feat of understanding and producing words in a
fraction of a second?
Um,
where does that ability come from?
There's a study of reading,
which is in many ways different from the study of language.
Um,
remember when Darwin describe language as an instinct,
he carefully distinguished it from other things that don't come natural to us,
including reading.
Um,
and in fact,
reading is difficult reading as a cultural invention.
Not every human has it.
And unlike language reading is acquired with tremendous difficulty over many
years.
And the other hand reading plainly intersects with language.
It's a new way of conveying language.
Moving out from speech to writing and a psychology and neuroscience of reading
is the US.
Very interesting.
There's bilingualism and multilingualism.
The questions people in this room typically are going to be interested in is,
um,
does it matter for how well you learn language,
whether you're learning one or two or three or four.
Um,
how is it that are multilingual in codes all these different languages inside a
single brain and so on.
Finally a very hot issue is that of the relationship between language and
thought.
And I'm,
and I'm actually,
I,
a few years ago I taught an entire seminar called language and thought devoted
to precisely this question.
And it's a cool question and it could break up into two very general questions.
One is,
is language necessary for abstract thought?
And one way to answer that question is to look at creatures without language
like babies and chimpanzees and see how smart they are.
It might be that they're not,
that they're very smart,
in which case it would suggest that you don't need language for abstract
thought.
On the other hand,
it might be that they have certain cognitive limitations which would suggest
that language is essential for abstract thought.
Then there's a related question.
Even once know a language.
Does the structural properties of the language that you know affect the way you
think and the claim that the language you know affects how you think is
sometimes described as linguistic relativity or this happened or warf
hypothesis.
So,
for instance,
there's a lot of research looking at speakers of different languages such as
English versus Korean,
and seeing whether structural differences in these languages affect how you
think.
Now,
some of this work is discussed in the readings,
uh,
the both the gray text book and the selections from the Norton Anthology.
And this makes up,
again,
I've showed this to you on Monday.
You're reading response where you have to address this question and,
and take your best shot at answering it.
Okay.
What are your questions about language?
Yes,
the question was raised,
some people learn languages easier than others.
And how do we explain this?
And the answer is,
um,
you could ask the question both with regard to first language learning.
So some children learn language,
uh,
very quickly.
Some are very slow.
And also with regard to second language learning,
some of you are breezing through your second language requirement here at Yale.
Others are struggling and miserable.
Um,
and there's considerable variation.
There's a story of Einstein who was very slow to learn language and didn't speak
at all until he was four.
And in fact,
he was,
uh,
he said his first words when all of a sudden he was having separate with his
parents and he put down the spoon and he's,
and he said,
the soup is too hot.
And his parents did.
I'm astonished and said,
you've never spoken before.
And he said,
well,
up to now,
everything has been fine.
It's not a,
it's not a true story.
Um,
the question of why and where do these differences come from?
Nobody really knows.
And it's surprisingly hard.
There's a slight advantage for being female.
Girls are slightly more advanced in language than boys,
but it's not a big one.
And you need like a hundred people to just see it statistically.
Um,
there's you a big genetic factor.
If your parents learned language quickly and learn other languages quickly,
you're more likely to,
but,
and understanding of the brain bases of these differences are the cognitive
basis or social basis is,
it's just,
it's largely an open question.
Yes.
Yeah.
Speak two different languages.
Uh,
this is actually more than norm around the world than the situation.
Neither states where kids are exposed to a single language.
Um,
what happens is children learn both languages.
Children are very good as adults are of distinguishing different languages on a
basis that are sound system and her rhythms.
So they don't typically confuse them and then they just learn more than one
language.
And that's actually more the average state of affairs around the world.
Yes.
Um,
the question is about the hemispheric specialization for language.
And I don't have actually much more to say than what I said before,
which I agree is deeply unsatisfying.
If you're right handed,
language is probably in the left side of your brain.
How many people here are lefthanded
okay
for you?
We don't know.
It varies.
Some of you have in the left side,
some of you have it in the right side for some of you is kind of die fuse.
Now,
why is this?
And in fact,
why are some people right handed and others left hand in the first place?
Those are really good questions.
Yes,
yes.
I mean,
yes,
I'll answer that question.
I'm unfortunate it's gotta be the last one.
And then I'll go to two to vision.
The question is,
does learning more than one language cause you to learn them slower than just
learning one language and it would stand to reason that a would,
there's a finite amount of mental resources.
If I'm just learning English,
I use all of it for English.
If I'm learning English and Spanish,
I kind of got a split and you'd expect them to be each learned slower.
It's one of the surprises of the study of language development that that common
sense for you does not appear to be true.
Troller and learning more than one language seemed to show no deficits,
um,
relative in each of their languages relative to a child learning just one
language.
In other words,
if I am just learning English and I'm a kid and you're learning English and
Spanish and you're a kid,
you'll reach the milestones in English the same time I will.
Your extra learning of Spanish doesn't seem to affect you.
Um,
there doesn't need to be any detriment for learning multiple languages.
Another question which comes up,
um,
is,
is there any cognitive deficit?
In other words,
some people have argued at learning multiple languages,
sometimes harm his children in certain ways.
This is a claim that's been made,
um,
in Quebec for instance,
over the debate over how children should be taught and French.
It does not appear to be the case.
There appears to be as far as we know,
no downside to learning many languages when you're young.
Does that answer your,
your question?
I want to move now to the topic that will take us through today and through the
beginning of next week.
Um,
perception,
attention and memory and I'm putting them together.
Um,
instead of treating them as separate lectures because there's a sense in which
they're the same story.
Um,
you'll see a scene,
you see this scene and you're looking at it and you're perceiving it is coming
through your eyes and you're interpreting it.
It,
you see something,
you see a man and you see a house.
If you were to shut your eyes,
you could still hold that scene and memory
and a week later if I'm to ask you about that,
like what season was it?
He would do pretty well.
This is a story I want to talk about how we do this and in the course of this I
want to make a series of of of claims.
Um,
that goes something like this for perception.
I want to first persuade you the problem with perceptions hard
and that's successful.
Perception involves educating unconscious guesses about the world for attention.
I want to suggest that we attend to some things and not others and we miss a
surprising amount of what happens in the world
for memory.
There are many types of memory.
The key to memories,
organization,
understanding and you can't trust some of your memories.
How many of you remember where you were at nine 11.
Many of you are wrong
and I am never going to persuade you with us because you have certain memories
and you could tell the story.
Everybody could tell a story where they were when the towers went down.
But clever psychologist on September 12th said,
let's do a study.
And they asked people,
where were you yesterday when you heard the news?
And they told them and then they went back to them later.
A year later,
two years later and said,
tell me about what happened September 11th.
Then we said,
I remember totally where I was.
I have a very,
and and often a story.
It was wrong.
There was a lot like that,
which we're gonna talk about.
And the biggest moral then,
so I put it really in really big print.
Um,
we are often wrong about our experiences,
both of the present and,
and,
and have right now.
So let's start with perception.
There's a story.
I went to graduate school at Mit and there was a story there about Marvin
Minsky,
who's the AI girl.
He 'em if you've heard of the words,
the phrase artificial intelligence,
that was him.
And if you heard the claim that people are nothing more than machines made of
meat,
also him.
Well,
there's a story where he was doing work on robotics and he was interested in
building a robot that could do all sorts of cool things.
That's like a robot.
And the story goes,
the robot had to,
um,
among that I had to rate,
had to,
to see the world.
It had to be able to pick up things and recognize people and see chairs and
navigate its way.
And Minsky said,
that's a tough problem.
It's going to take a graduate student a whole summer to figure it out.
And he assigned it to a graduate student for a summer project.
Um,
visual psychologists,
perception.
Psychologists love that story because the study of computer vision and robotics
vision and the attempts to make machines that can identify and recognize objects
has been a profound failure.
There is at this point,
no machine on earth that could recognize people and objects and things at the
level of,
you know,
a really dumb one year old.
And the reason why is that it's a much harder problem than anybody could have
expected.
Well,
what makes it such a hard problem?
One reason why you might think is an easy problem is you say,
okay,
we have to figure out the problem of how people see,
well,
here's what we do.
You're,
you're over there and here's your eye.
And somehow it has to get to this television monitor and then you look at it and
that'll solve the problem of how you see.
So sometimes people say,
Hey,
I hear the,
I flip things upside down.
I guess this guy is going to have to get used to looking at things upside down.
That's an interesting problem.
No,
that's not the way to look at it.
Cause that doesn't,
um,
that doesn't answer any questions.
That just pushes the question back,
fine,
how does he z we're not answering anything.
Similarly,
although the terminators view of the world may correspond to that,
that doesn't solve any problem with how he actually sees.
So he has all these numbers shooting out there.
Well you have to read the numbers.
He has to see this.
This is my iTunes.
Um,
in,
in that version,
here's,
here's the right way to think about perception.
Um,
you got the eye,
which is very ugly and bloody.
And then around here you have the retina and the retina is a bunch of nerve
cells and the nerve cells fire as for some stimulus and not others.
And from this array of firings firing,
not firing,
firing,
not firing.
You have to figure out what the world is.
So a better view is like this,
the firings of the neurons can be viewed as an array of numbers.
You have to figure out how to get from the numbers to objects and people.
MMM.
And to actions and events.
And that's the problem.
It's made particularly a difficult problem because the retina is a two
dimensional surface and you have to infer a three d world from a two dimensional
surface.
And this is from a mathematical point of view,
impossible.
And what this means is that there,
for any two dimensional image,
there is an indefinite number of three dimensional images that correspond to it.
So for instance,
suppose you had this on your retina.
Okay.
An array of like shape like that,
what does that correspond to in the world?
Well,
it could correspond to a thing just like that that you're looking for or it
could correspond to a square that's tilted backwards.
And so you have to figure out which is which.
And the way we solve this problem
is that we have unconscious assumptions about how the world works.
Our minds contain certain assumptions about how things should be that enable us
to make educated guesses from the two dimensional array onto the three
dimensional world.
And I purposefully did not make the slides available for this class ahead of
time cause I don't want people to cheat.
But there are several points where you could look at the slides and confirmed
that some of the things I'm going to tell you are actually true.
Um,
and I want to give you three examples.
One is color and I'm going to conflate here.
Color and brightness and others objects the others depth.
First,
the prom of color.
How do you tell a lump of coal from a snowball?
Well,
that's a lumper call as a snowball.
It's from Google images.
Um,
how do you know which is which?
Well,
Alumba call you say is black and the snowball is white.
How do you know?
Well,
maybe have on your red.
Now you're reading their responses or the color that hits it.
It's oversimplified,
but let's assume the desk.
It's true.
So this is black coming out and that's white and that's how you tell.
But in fact,
that can't be right.
It can't be right because objects color is not merely a matter of what material
they're made of,
but of the amount of light that hits it.
So as I walk across the stage,
I fall into shadow and light and none of you screams out.
Professor Bloom is changing colors.
Um,
rather you automatically factor out the change in illumination,
um,
as this is happening,
and this could actually be quite striking.
So you see this display over here,
pick a look at those two blocks.
I take it you see this one as lighter than that one you do.
Um,
you might imagine this is because this strip is lighter than this,
but it isn't there the same.
Yeah.
And you won't believe me until you actually print it out and take a look.
But they are in fact the same.
I'll show it to you and you could say I'm tricking you,
but this is the way it works.
There's a closeout.
So remember we're comparing this and this.
Now,
let's take away other parts of the environment
and you'll see they're the same.
Now you say,
but hold it.
This can't be the same as this,
but the answer is goes like this.
Okay,
we know shadows make surfaces darker.
We don't know this like,
Hey,
here's something I know.
Rather we know this in that is wired up in our brains,
so when we see a surface in shadow,
we automatically assume that it's lighter than it looks and we see it as lighter
and you can show this by removing the cubes to the shadow.
You see it as it really is,
and this is an illustration of how the information to your eyes,
it's just one bit of information that the degree of light coming from a single
source is one bit of information that you use to calculate certain assumptions
and come to a conclusion.
Here's a different kind of example.
Objects.
You see this and you automatically and intuitively segmented into different
objects.
You segmented into a man and a house and birds and trees.
How do you do this?
It turns out to program a computer to segment a scene.
At the different objects.
It's hugely difficult.
And the question of how we do it is to some extent unknown.
But one answer to this question is there are certain cues in the environment
that are signals that you're dealing with different objects and these cues are
often described as your stall principles.
So one example is proximity.
When you see things that are close to each other,
you're more likely than not to assume that they belonged to the same thing.
There is similarity.
That display could correspond to an an indefinite number of objects,
but you naturally tend to see it as too,
um,
you,
you do one with one texture pattern.
The other with the other texture pattern closure,
the fact that this is a close square here suggests it's a single object,
good continuation.
If you had to judge,
this could just as well be two shapes,
one that runs from a to see the other one that runs from D to B,
but you don't to see it that way.
Rather,
you tend to see it as one that runs from a to B.
The other one that runs from c to d common movement.
If things move together,
they're a single object and good form.
You see the object over there.
In the absence of any other information,
you might be tempted to say that's a single thing,
a plus sign.
Maybe this because it has lousy form.
You're more tempted to say it's two things.
One thing lying on top of each other.
And these are the sorts of cues,
expectations.
None of them are right.
There's cases where they could all fool you,
but these are useful cues that guide our parsing of the world are segmenting of
the world into distinct objects.
Here are there,
summarize and here's a case where they fool you.
So you might think if you're,
I'm suggestible that there's a triangle here and this is a case where there's
certain cues driving you to think that there's a triangle here.
There is however,
no triangle here.
If you cover up these little PAC men here,
the triangle goes away.
Similarly,
there is no square in the middle.
There is no square.
It's very matrix.
Um,
and these are illusions because these are cues that there should be a square
there.
The regularity of form
finally depth.
Um,
you see this and you don't,
you see it on one level as a flat thing,
another level.
You look inside the picture and you see,
for instance,
that the man is in front of the house.
You look at me and you see the podium.
And if you have a terrible neurological disorder,
you see this strange creature that's half podium leading onto a chest and up to
a head that's sort of the top items wiggling in a podium,
staying still.
If you are neurologically normal,
you see a man walking back and forth behind a podium.
How do you do that?
Well,
this is really a problem because I can give you a technical reason why vision is
hard.
But crudely,
you got a two dimensional retina and you have to figure out a three dimensional
world.
How do you do it?
And the answer,
once again is assumptions or cubes.
Um,
there's certain assumptions the visual system makes that aren't always right.
And in fact,
in cases of visual,
illusions can be wrong,
but we'll guide you to perceive the world in a correct and accurate way.
So for example,
there's binocular disparity.
This is actually a sort of interesting one.
This is the only depth cue that involves two eyes.
If I look at you pretty close,
um,
the image I get here and the image I get here are somewhat different while,
or I have to focus my eyes together to get the same image.
If I look at you and back,
they're almost identical because the further away given the two eyes that are
static,
the closer to images,
luck.
And it's not again,
that you say to yourself,
oh,
back there an orange.
It's the same image in my right eye and my left eye.
He must be far away rather unconsciously and automatically.
You make estimations on how far people are in depth based on binocular
disparity.
There's interposition.
How do you know I'm in front of the podium and the podium is not in front of me?
No.
How do you know the podiums in front of me?
Well from where I'm standing,
it's right.
How do you know the podium is in front of me?
Well,
because you know,
I'm walking here and then it cuts into me and unless I'm going through a
grotesque metamorphosis,
um,
what's happening is it makes sense to say I'm moving behind the podium.
Interposition you take the guy,
how do you know the guy standing in front of the house?
Well,
um,
because uh,
there's,
you see all of him and he's blocking a lot of the house.
There's relative size.
How far away am I?
Well,
if you looked at me and you had to estimate how far away I am,
part of the way you'll figure that out is,
you know how tall a human's supposed to be.
If you thought that I was 50 feet tall,
you would assume I'm further away than I am.
And so your judgments on size dictate your judgments about distance.
Usually this queue is unnecessary.
But you know,
if you look at the empire state building,
if you,
if you go into a field and you see a tower and you look your judgment of how far
away the tower's going to be depends on on your,
your knowledge of how tall the tower should be.
If it's like this tall,
he's like,
oh,
it must be,
and then you'd be surprised.
There's
texture gradient,
which I'll explain in a second and linear perspective,
which will also explain in a second texture gradient goes like this.
Remember the problem we had before?
How do you know if that thing is this object tilted backwards or an object in
and of itself?
Well,
the answer is things with textures will show themselves because the texture
will,
will get smaller from a distance.
Now logically,
this could still be a single thing standing upright.
We've just dots going up smaller.
But the natural assumption is the reason why the dots received in his regular
fashion is because it's receding in depth.
Okay.
Classic illusion.
Um,
the Mueller lawyer illusion,
people will see this as longer than this.
It's not,
if you don't believe me,
print it out and measure it.
Um,
related to the Pondo illusion.
Once again,
people see this one as you get an illusions named after you when you discovered
these,
um,
this one as longer than this.
Again,
it's not what's going on here.
Well the top line looks longer even though it isn't.
And one re explanation for why is these other lines in the scene cause your
visual system to make guesses about distance and then you correct for distance
by making assumptions about size.
If you have two lines,
you getting a bit more detail in a second.
But if you have two lines and they take up the same amount of space on your
retina,
but you believe that one is a hundred feet away and the other is 50 feet away,
the one that's a hundred feet away you will see as bigger.
Cause your brain will say,
well if it takes up just this much space,
but it's further away,
it must be bigger than somebody that's closer.
It takes up that much space
and that's what goes on here for the top line.
For the mule Royer illusion.
Um,
we assumed that this is further away and this is closer based on the cues to
distance and the q's factored in.
And because we assume that this is further away,
we assume it must be bigger to take up the same space as this,
which is closer.
Similarly for the Panto illusion,
there's linear perspective.
Power lines tend to recede and distance.
Um,
if this top one is further away than this,
but they take up the same size in your eye,
this one must be bigger and you see it as bigger.
And the book offers more details on how these illusions work.
I'm going to end with an illusion that I'm not even gonna bother explaining.
Um,
I'll just show it to you because you should be able to based on thinking about
these other illusions,
figure it out.
It was developed by Roger Shepard.
Oh,
you know that.
Um,
and it were called Sheppard tables.
And the thing about it,
if these are like two tables,
if you ask people you don't frame in terms of here's a lecture and visual,
but that you'd ask people,
where'd you,
these tables would be easier to get through a door.
If you have a thin door,
he will say the one on the left,
um,
this one looks sort of thicker and harder to get through them.
It looks longer and leaner,
in fact,
at the same size.
What I mean by that is that this triangle is exactly the same as this triangle.
Now I'm going to prove it to you by showing you is hunting,
which took me on the computer,
which took me about seven hours to do.
And nobody's going to believe it because I could have faked it.
But if you want printed out and do it yourself,
you just take a piece of paper,
put it on here,
then you move it
the same.
I showed it to somebody.
They call me a liar.
Anyway,
you're going to do it yourself in the privacy of your own home or study.
Um,
but
what I'd really like you to do after you do it is say,
okay,
fine,
why does this one look longer and thinner than this one?
And the answer is the same answer that will explain the Mueller lawyer illusion
of Pando illusion having to do with Qsa depth and the way your mind corrects the
perception of depth.
And that's all I have to say at this point about perception.
I want to move now to attention and memory.
Um,
and I'm on a treat attention and memory together.
We are,
I'm fascinated with memory and in particular it's particularly interesting when
memory goes wrong.
Um,
it's particularly fascinating what happens in cases of Amnesia.
So for example,
um,
I need like a volunteer who's like willing to do a little bit of acting,
very little bit,
incredibly,
a little bit real.
Excellent.
Okay.
So these,
this data,
so pretend you have amnesia.
Okay.
What's your name?
Perfect.
I'm really glad you said that.
That's the wrong answer because you don't have total amnesia.
You still remember English.
Okay.
It's very clever.
So,
so you couldn't have lost all your memories.
You have English you,
so we'll do you,
what's your name?
Ah,
he looks puzzled but he still maintains bowel and bladder control.
So he hasn't forgotten everything.
Now
I always,
I always lose lose the third volunteering I'd demo.
Um,
so memory is a hugely broad concept.
It includes autobiographical memory,
which is what we standardly think.
I mean that,
that's a perfectly rational response.
When I say [inaudible] me losing their memory,
Oh,
I have a movie about somebody losing their memory.
You don't imagine a person in diapers.
You imagine a person walking around having sex with cool people and saying,
where am I?
And you know,
and so will you imagine is you imagine them losing their autobiographical
memory,
their sense of self.
But of course,
knowing English as part of your memory and knowing how to stand and knowing how
to chew and swallow are all things that you've learned that you've had been
molded by experience.
Um,
there's another distinction which is going to come in regarding Amnesia,
which is there's broadly two types of Amnesia.
They often run together,
but one type of Amnesia is you lose your memory of the past.
Another type of Amnesia.
That's,
that's the Matt Damon Amnesia.
Um,
another type of Amnesia though,
is you lose the ability to form new memories.
And here's a film of a man who had exactly this problem.
Um,
he was a world renowned choir director and he's suffered,
um,
viral encephalitis,
which led to brain damage,
which destroyed most of his temporal lobes.
Um,
his hippocampus and a lot of his left frontal frontal lobe.
It could be,
it could have been worse.
I mean,
and that he retains the ability to talk and he seems to eat.
He's not intellectually impaired.
You just can't form new memories.
And so he lives in his perpetual.
Now where does nothing affects him.
And he feels this is not,
this is not always happen.
There's more than one of these cases and it doesn't always happen like this,
but he feels continually reborn at every moment.
Um,
and we'll return to this and then ask what's going on here.
But there's a few themes here.
Uh,
I want to,
before getting into detail about memory,
I want to review some basic distinctions in memory.
When we talk about memory.
So crudely,
you can make a distinction being sensory memory,
short term memory,
which is also known as working memory and long term memory.
Sensory memory is a residue.
In your census there was a flash of lightening.
You might see an afterimage that after image is your sensory memory.
Um,
there's somewhat of a longer echoic memory for sounds.
So as somebody who's talking to you,
even if you're not paying attention,
you'll store a few seconds of what they're saying,
which is sometimes when somebody is talking to you and you're not listening to
them and they say,
you're not listening to me.
And he said,
no.
You were talking about and pick up the last couple of seconds from echoic memory
are short term memory.
Um,
anybody remember what I just said?
If you did that short term memory spans for,
for a few minutes and then there's long term memory.
Anybody know who Elvis is?
Do you know your name?
Do you know where you live,
your longterm memory store that you walk around with and you're not gonna lose
right away.
Um,
when we think about Amnesia in the movie sense,
we think of a certain loss of longterm memory,
long term memory associated with autobiographical personal events.
There's the distinction between employee implicit and explicit,
which we'll talk about it and more detailed but explicit crudely is what you
have conscious access to.
So,
um,
what you had for dinner last night,
you could think back and say,
I had this for dinner last night.
Implicit is more unconscious.
Um,
what the word,
what certain word,
like what the word had means.
Um,
how to walk,
how to ride a bicycle.
You might not be able to articulate,
might not even be conscious of,
but still have access to.
Um,
there's a distinction between semantic memory and episodic memory.
Semantic memory is basically facts,
what a word means,
what's the capital of Canada and so on.
Um,
episodic.
His autobiography is what happened to you,
um,
that,
that Yale is a new haven is semantic,
um,
that you went on vacation away from new haven last week.
It would be episodic.
Uh,
there is encoding storage and retrieval which refers to different levels of um,
what happens in memory in coding is getting the memory in a,
as when you study for a test or you have an experience and a storage is holding
the memory and retrieval is getting the memory out.
Um,
finally,
retrieval is often broken conveniently into recall versus recognition where
recall is when you,
um,
you just pull it out of memory and recognition is when you,
you recognize what corresponds to certainly gonna pass.
Anybody remember what color tie I had on two days ago?
Oh,
okay.
Well that would be impossible to remember.
But if I asked you is it purple or is it orange?
That would be much easier.
Um,
now you could break up crudely the memory into stages.
So you started sensory memory is just the stuff that comes in leading to short
term memory,
leading to long term memory.
And this stage there is unusual discuss in more detail,
but this leads us to the issue of attention.
How did he get memory from your sensations?
From what you're hearing,
I'm speaking to you and you're hearing me.
How does it ever get in to the other systems?
What decides what's remembered and what's not?
There's all sorts of things happening to you now.
Um,
the seat of your chair is pressing against your,
but you don't think,
oh,
I want to remember this forever.
The seats pressing against my butt.
You know,
your,
your neighbor's exuding a certain sort of smell.
You're,
you're,
you're thinking about something.
Your eyes follow them.
Not everything gets in memory.
You'd go mad if you tried to remember everything.
You can't.
So what determines what gets into memory?
Well,
one answer is attention does and attention is,
could be crudely viewed as a flashlight,
a spotlight on experience that willingly zooms in on something
and makes it memorable.
Attention has certain properties.
Some things come from attention to attention effortlessly and automatically.
Here's an example.
You're going to see an array of letters here.
One of them's going to be green.
When you see the green one,
please clap.
Okay.
No,
no,
not,
not this green one.
There's gotta be another method.
Why?
Okay,
you're ready now.
now fine.
Not that old,
but,
but
there's going to be an oh,
when you see it,
clap.
Okay.
Sometimes it's,
it's work.
Find the red.
Oh,
it's harder.
Sometimes it's pension is involuntary.
Um,
I need,
I need a volunteer and all I want to do is I'm going to show you colors on the
screen and I'd like you to name the colors as they come out.
Oh,
okay.
The first one's easy.
Hey,
is this,
you have to just go down the colors.
Anybody?
Okay.
Red,
green,
blue,
black.
Green,
blue.
Red,
Black.
Red.
Excellent.
Okay.
Now these,
these will be words,
but just name.
Okay.
You just name it.
Just name.
Just name the colors.
Okay.
Green.
Red,
blue.
Black.
Blue,
red,
green.
Black.
Red,
blue.
Perfect.
Now we'll go back to you.
Same deal words.
Red,
blue.
Don't I know you can read the colors.
Okay.
Blue,
green,
red,
black.
Green.
Blue.
Black.
Right.
Red,
black.
Very good.
Actually.
That's,
that's known as the stroop effect.
Being an expert reader.
As you are,
your knowledge of reading your attention to what the words meant,
subverted,
um,
you're a desire to do the task.
You couldn't make that go away even if you want it to.
If somebody gave you $1,000 to read this as fast as you read this,
and as fast as you read this,
you'd be unable to.
You can't block it.
Um,
there's some work.
There's some interesting discoveries about attention.
I have a demonstration here.
I'd like people,
actually,
it's important.
Some of you may have seen this before.
Um,
it's important for you to be silent throughout it.
Where you're going to see is you're going to see two teams,
the basketball players.
One of them is going to,
um,
have a white t shirts.
The other one will have black tee shirts.
There'll be passing balls back and forth,
but I'd like you to do is count in your head how many passes the white team does
with the ball.
What,
what number did people get?
Okay?
Did anybody notice anything unusual?
Did anybody not notice anything unusual?
Okay.
Some people,
some people did not notice anything unusual.
Those who didn't see anything unusual,
watch this again and just watch it.
Um,
about 50% of people when counting who have never seen this before,
don't notice anything.
But then when you're not counting,
it's kind of obvious what you're missing.
Yeah.
And this is one demonstration among many
of the fact that when you're attending to something,
you have a very small window of attention and you lose the focus on other
things.
Here's another different example,
like people to watch a movie and pay attention very closely to what happens in
the movie and try to remember this.
How many of you noticed something odd in that movie?
How many of you didn't?
Okay.
Now everybody look at the,
look at the scarf,
the color of the plates and the food,
among other things.
The phenomena in general has been called changed blindness.
And what it is is we tend to be,
when there's a focus of attention focused in a certain way,
we tend to be oblivious to other things that go on in the environment.
Often it is in fact quite difficult when there's a change in scene to notice
what changes and what stays the same.
So in this final demo,
um,
there's this going to be two pictures.
Flicking.
Could you clap when you see what's different between the two pictures?
Okay.
I,
I myself,
I'm terrible at these things have less empathy.
How many people never saw it.
All
right,
that's very impressive.
One more.
One more time with a different one.
Did anybody not see it?
Be Honest.
I'll give you another try.
Okay.
I'll put you out of your misery.
MMM.
This is work by Dan Simons and,
and it's,
um,
it's part of an extraordinarily interesting body of work on what's known as
changed blindness.
And what this means is the phenomena is we,
um,
we have a very narrow focus of attention and huge changes can happen that we are
oblivious to.
This is why in movies are so many,
so much difficulty with continuity changes.
Um,
Dan Simons is also famous for having brought this outside of the laboratory.
in some classic experiments.
I'm trying to get the film corresponding to them.
What he did was he did this great study in the Cornell campus where he was,
where what would happen is
they would get some unsuspecting person walking through campus and some guy
would come over and say,
excuse me,
sir,
I'm,
I'm lost.
Could you help me with directions and have a map and then any,
sure.
And then there'd be two construction workers holding a door and these guys were
going to rudely bump between these two characters and then the experimenter who
gets switched with another guy.
So now when these two guys walk away that the subject is standard with an
entirely different person.
MMM.
What's interesting is nobody notices.
They notice if the person changes sexist,
if then you used to be a woman.
Yeah.
Notice if the sub,
if the experiment or changes racist,
but most other changes,
they're oblivious to.
Um,
there's another experiment,
I think Brian Shoulder,
this one.
Um,
but they've been Dan Simons,
um,
where,
what happens is subject comes into the lab.
They say,
you know,
you got to do an experiment with us.
Um,
uh,
you need to sign the human subject for him,
handsome to form experimenter,
the subject science to form experimenter takes the form,
says thank you,
I'll put it down here,
goes down here and in a different person pops up,
people don't notice.
Um,
and,
and there's a certain level in which we're oblivious to changes.
What's weird is we don't see,
we don't think we are.
We think we see the world as it is and we don't know.
Notice that when we're attending to something,
everything else gets blanked out.
And so about 50% of people who have never seen this demo before the gorilla
demo,
they don't notice the gorilla.
And there was,
you couldn't imagine anything more obvious.
The gorilla study was actually done a very long time ago and it was originally
done in a different way,
but I'll show it to you just because,
um,
this is the original study and that you all know what to expect.
Um,
oh,
not that one.
Oops.
Nope.
That's actually,
if you looked at that quickly,
it's a current Yale professor.
Oh,
I'm never going to get my DVD back.
Anyway,
I'll show you the other,
the other demo on.
Um,
next week
I will,
um,
any questions about attention and memory at this point?
Yeah.
Yup.
Why?
Why does it work that way?
Why is it,
why do things that become very practice become automatic and involuntary?
It's a good question.
I don't know.
We know that they do.
We know that once you,
um,
that you can't not read once you know how to read,
you also can't not listen.
You know,
if,
if I'm talking to you and I'm extremely boring,
but I'm talking,
he was very hard not to listen.
You can't shut off your ears.
You can put your fingers in them,
but you can't shut off here.
You also can't shut your eyes without actually shutting them.
You can't say,
this is a disgusting movie.
I'm not going to attend to it.
So that's not answering your question.
It's just saying that,
that your observation is a right one and a more general one.
When you're good at something and you're over practice,
it becomes involuntary and you cannot stop it.
Okay.
Well.
Oh,
one one more and back.
Yes.
Why not?
Sorry.
Over there.
Yep.
Did he remember things before his accident?
Yes,
he,
he had some Amnesia of events before his accident,
but he did remember things like he knew his name and he knew other things about
his wife.
Okay.
I'll see you next week.